ils veulent être champion du département
ce weekend le club de tir à l'arc de
Guill encs organiser le championnat
départemental jeune des Yvelines pour
nos championnats de département on
s'aligne sur le championnat régional
c'estàd qu'on demande aux personnes
d'avoir fait au moins trois concours
pour pouvoir se sélectionner c'est un un
honneur de venir faire un départemental
d'où on prend pas des gens qui ont des
des scorses très très bas on essaie
quand même de garder l'élite du
département pour avoir des bons
résultats 14 catégories en arc classique
et Arc pouli étent représentés de U11 à
U21 près de 70 jeunes venus de tout le
département correspondaient au critères
de sélection dont la jeune Alicia
chambre membre de l'équipe de France
al très bien très très bien oui pour
l'instant ça va
duune oui après le mieux c'est atteindre
cette zone un championnat c'est un
championnat il faut pas le prendre comme
si c'était rien ça fait toujours un
entraînement avec des gens connait là
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'était de
prendre plaisir de faire bah comme quand
je m'entraîne à l'entraînement faire un
score et voilà prochain rendez-vous le
weekend qui arrive avec les régionales
en scène Saint-Denis